[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Tuesday May 23rd I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade last year politicians and abortion
rights supporters have expressed concern
that cell phone data could be used to
identify women suspected of seeking
abortions but exclusive wsj reporting
has found that as early as 2019 and up
until a year ago a group called Veritas
Society an arm of the anti-abortion
organization Wisconsin right to life was
using cell phone location data to Target
advertising at women who had visited
Planned Parenthood clinics neither
Veritas Society nor Wisconsin Right to
Life responded to requests for comment
with me to discuss what happened and how
it fits into the broader picture of data
collection is our reporter Byron Tao who
wrote this story with reporter patience
Hagen Byron how did Veritas Society get
this type of precise location data so
this is the kind of data that's
collected by apps so basically consumers
opt into an app's location services
allow that app to know their location
and then that location is shared with
advertisers who are able to Target
things like targeted ads say you go to a
certain restaurant or you frequent a
certain bar advertisers can Target you
based on your geographical location if
you've allowed an app or some sort of
digital service to know your location
cell phone information for their
advertising so we managed to piece this
together with a combination of human
sources as well as some documents that
Veritas society that posted on their
website as late as last year which
essentially described an advertising
campaign that would capture the unique
device identifiers whose locations
showed them at Planned Parenthood
clinics around the country and then use
that information to Target them as they
browse the web or they went on Facebook
or SnapChat what did the advertising
company that help them collect this
information say about that so they
basically used a company called near
intelligence to what's called geofence
these Planned Parenthood clinics that
means essentially just drawing a a
square or a circle around Planned
Parenthood locations and seeing what
devices appeared in that specific
location this company has policies
against doing that however it's very
difficult to police what happens on
their platform and they did eventually
suspend this campaign but it went on for
a while before it was caught what did
the advertisements that Veritas Society
ran look like a lot of them were aimed
at women who had taken one of a series
of pills to induce a medicated abortion
and that involved telling them that it
might be possible to save their
pregnancy by taking a different drug we
should say this is an unproven
scientific procedure that many doctors
say is not supported by scientific
evidence but essentially this is what
this ad was targeted at women who were
considering or had taken the first in a
series of pills that might induce
medical abortion and you said Those ads
appeared on social media I mean what
kind of platforms and what did those
platforms say about having these ads and
this kind of targeting there we know
they were trying to reach consumers on
Snapchat Instagram and Facebook at least
and the way they set up the campaign
also allowed them to later Target those
people as they were moved around other
websites the three main social media
Services all said that various aspects
of this campaign violated their internal
rules and said that they had pulled down
the ads did the veritas Society or
Wisconsin Right to Life comment on this
story neither of those groups responded
to our request for comment and what
about Planned Parenthood Planned
Parenthood called the ads Veritas
Society was running quote disinformation
and they said that Planned Parenthood is
committed to providing sexual and
reproductive health care and information
in a setting which preserve and protect
the essential privacy and rights of
everyone
legal for something like this to go on
there's no explicit federal law that
bans the targeting of abortion clinics
for digital advertising that said the
FTC in recent months has advanced a
legal theory that basically the selling
of information on consumers just like
this might be a violation of some
consumer protection laws though we
should say that their initial lawsuit on
the matter involved none of these
parties and was rejected by a judge
separately a bunch of states have
actually passed comprehensive privacy
laws and many of those state laws do
deal with things like health information
or precise geolocation but as of right
now there's no overarching federal U.S
Privacy Law that would prevent something
like this from happening how do groups
like Veritas society and advertising
companies that use geofencing feel about
the fact that some Regulators are trying
to crack down on this practice a bit
more the digital advertising industry is
a multi-billion Dollar business and a
lot of money is wrapped up in knowing
details about consumers and a lot of
content on the web is paid for this way
and so in general
rejiggering the way we pay for Content
the way we get apps is a huge
undertaking where there are a lot of
players with a lot of vested interests
in keeping the status quo in general
Congress has struggled with how to
balance these competing priorities and
as of right now there's no federal
comprehensive Privacy Law and
one did to protect their data is there a
way they could do it then
the most basic thing you can do to
protect your location data is to
basically not let apps know your
location unless they need to many modern
smartphone operating systems allow you
to just share location when you need it
so when you're calling a ride share or
when you're checking the weather rather
than a 24 7 access to location and many
of these apps work just fine if you turn
the location off and tell the app where
you are manually alright that was wsj
reporter Byron Tau
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]